so you must be Brian I am sir the
Hetalia and the 34 year old I do it off
you do it all is that what you are
seriously 34 right you know what
I'm 33 I work so hard I think I just
thought I was 34 you're 33 did you call
this building the Caribbean yes have you
ever been to the Caribbean yeah which
part
Hamas and this has been modeled on the
Bahamas correct did you smoke when you
in the Bahamas you know that I've tried
a couple of times surely stop yeah yeah
what hotel in the Caribbean or the
Bahamas were you running before you
bought this one so I've just visited the
Caribbean I've never ran a hotel in the
Caribbean so you just go buy yourself a
25 bedroom hotel on the beach with the
bar and all I know how to do is run a
fish market when I open this and I pick
from the scratch from the ground up it's
the fish is fresh obviously from the
market
they're so fresh right I better jump in
table for you right here thanks sir
thank you yeah please
I'm excited to the fresh fish is so
surreal bro Gordon ran and died on us
with the main tanks I mean you're the
owner right I think I should lead by
example so I I'd like to wear mine that
way if I tell them that they need to
wear them then they can't say well Brian
you don't wear yours right I'm starving
I'm gonna get you some food right away
I'm gonna give you a great server [ __ ]
you grace Kelly how long you been there
um I've been here about a year nice and
I was never told even our first shirts
our name tags bonnet I get well yeah we
have to be like $8.00 more a name tag
from fellas a t-shirt that's $20 we come
to [ __ ] work
Wow as I look at their menu I noticed
it's absolutely massive so I decided to
all of the chicken wings which honestly
I wasn't surprised when they were dry
then I had the lobster mac and cheese
which technically isn't mac and cheese
because they used penne pasta but the
worst part of my lunch was the tuna
burger which I knew wasn't quite right
it is first I was frozen yes you said
fish market fresh fish daily frozen fish
fresh fish what's going we use frozen
sand dance sure and you have a fish
market that you bite on
yeah yeah I'm confused
ever since about four months ago
everything was fresh everything I ran up
a little bit of a bill with my brother
so we cut back and started ordering some
of the frozen stuff from some of the
purveyors and what's the feedback we get
some negative feedback I know it's a
blow to the ego but you knew it's gonna
be something with me everything I'm
explaining this monstrosity what in the
[ __ ] is going on here this is our kiosk
first and never damn products for a rice
all sorts of people so picks volleyballs
be vicious sick bags how busy is this
how was it going I honestly it doesn't
do that good
how many beach towels have you sold not
too many beeps downsize show you what
all right yeah I'd love to see one
please
[ __ ] disaster
we're on the beach we don't have towels
what is wrong with this picture
Musti thank you very much
whenever you're ready to go to the beach
whatever I'm ready to go to the beach
Wow how much have you stopped one